MINH NGUYEN: Welcome to
simplifying complex application
development using
Cloud Firestore.
My name is Minh Nguyen,
and I am a product manager
for Cloud Firestore.
We have an exciting
session today
that is composed of
two major sections.
The first section covers why
Cloud Firestore, and will
include key challenges
that Firestore
solves for along with a customer
testimonial from Khan academy.
The second section covers what's
new in Cloud Firestore, which
will provide a sneak peek into
exciting launches and a demo
of an upcoming feature.
Let's get started.
OK, face it, product
development is hard.
Not only do you have to
focus on providing value
through your core
business, you also
have to build complex
applications composed
of several components.
Applications typically
start with a database.
This is followed by APIs
in front of the database
to handle client queries.
Of course, you will have
to keep your data secure,
so you will need an app and
Auth player to manage both users
and access to the APIs.
Users expect applications to
be real time and collaborative,
so you'll have to define a
synchronization protocol.
And finally, since users have
internet network connectivity,
you'll have to add support
for offline mode as well.
Often these components
are produced
by several different
vendors, and it's up to you
to link or break them together.
Now, if your
application takes off,
you have to ensure that your
solution grows with demand.
That often means charting
and scaling your solution,
ensuring that your services are
set up for high availability,
and finally, managing major
version upgrades in security
patches which will often incur
some level of service downtime.
What if product development
could be made easier?
I'd like to introduce
you to Cloud Firestore,
a purpose built document
database service
that aims to make it easy
to develop applications.
Firestore is the successor
to cloud data store.
It incorporates technology from
the Firebase Realtime Database
for rapid application to open.
This service is available
both through Google Cloud
and the Firebase portfolio, and
provides seamless integrations
with both ecosystems.
So what makes Firestore special?
It's built to be server-less.
That means it's a
fully managed service
that automatically
scales based on demand
and has no maintenance windows.
It supports direct application
to database connections
and customizable security rules
to ensure that users can only
access or modify the data that
they're permitted to access.
It has built-in live
data synchronization
and offline mode making it
effortless to build real time
applications that can withstand
a network connectivity hiccup.
And finally, Firestore
has a rich array
of supported libraries
and frameworks
including those
supported by Google
and community maintained
libraries as well.
One of the key
attributes of Firestore
is that it's server-less.
From the external
developer's perspective,
Firestore offers a set
of APIs for document
reads, writes, and deletes.
Behind the covers, the service
D couples processing and storage
layers in order to automatically
scale both dimensions
independently to meet demand.
All data is stored across
multiple strongly consistent
replicas.
In our regional
offering of Firestore,
that means having an
availability SLA of 99.99%.
In our multi-regional
offering of Firestore,
that means having
a service that is
resilient to whole region
outage and availability
SLA of 99.999%.
As applications
perform additional read
and write operations
on the database,
the database uses automated
load and ranged-based
charting to scale processing
and storage with minimal impact
latency.
In practice, some customers
have scaled to tens of millions
of requests per second,
and petabytes of storage.
More interestingly, Firestore
is an elastic service
that can scale resource
utilization both up and down.
As a result, customers
only pay for what they use.
No capacity planning
is required.
Getting started
is also completely
free with a generous,
always free tier
to incubate your development.
Often, I get the question, how
is Firestore used in practice?
Let's go through three common
customer architectures.
OK, let's say that you
want to use Firestore
with server-less
attributes, but you
prefer to architect
your solution
utilizing a more traditional
approach that utilizes
compute services to govern
access to the database.
You're not, that setup
is fully supported.
In this architecture,
access to Firestore
is authenticated and
authorized through Cloud IAM.
Since Firestore is
transactional database,
this architecture
is often extended
to support analytical
workloads through a one click
integration with BigQuery
that leverages cloud
function triggers to
stream data changes.
What if you're an
application development
team that wants to reduce
development time and total
cost of ownership?
In this diagram, you
can see an architecture
that achieves just that.
Here, all applications
communicate directly
to the database utilizing
Firestore's client libraries.
Authentication is handled
through Firebase off or Google
Cloud Identity Platform.
Authorization is managed through
customizable Cloud Firestore
security rules.
Syncing is handled through
Firestore's persistent sockets
to the database.
Offline mode is managed through
Firestore's on device database.
Similar, the last
architecture diagram
to support analytical
workloads, we
recommend customers
set up a one click
integration with BigQuery.
If an application needs to
present analytical results back
to the end user, customers
can execute BigQuery
via Cloud Functions,
and store these results
in Cloud Firestore.
If live synchronization,
latest results
will automatically be
transmitted to listing
application connections.
If you already have an existing
legacy application and database
but are facing challenges with
high availability, scaling,
or simply trying to build out
features for your application,
including real time
collaboration in offline mode,
Cloud Firestore is for you.
We are frequently
seeing customers
use Cloud Firestore in front
of an existing legacy database
to take advantage of
these native capabilities.
In this architecture,
Cloud Firestore
has been added as the
primary serving database that
stands in front of a
legacy database system.
To ensure that business
processes can continue
to run on the legacy
database system,
data from Cloud
Firestore is often
periodically synced
using a pipeline service
like Cloud Dataflow.
Lastly, it's worth mentioning
that Cloud Firestore is
available in two modes.
Both modes utilize a shared
processing and storage layer.
[INAUDIBLE] stored mode is
fully compatible with Cloud
Datastore.
It's suitable for server
to Firestore connections.
Native mode consists of a new
document and collections data
model.
It also works for server
to Firestore connections.
This is the mode that
you want to select
if you want to enable direct
application to Firestore
connections.
OK, we've covered a
lot of information.
Let's hear from a real customer.
I would like to introduce
you to Marta Kosarchyn, who
is the chief technology
officer and vice president
of engineering at Khan academy.
Marta will be sharing
how Khan academy has
used Firestore to respond
to a surge of demand
of online education.
MARTA KOSARCHYN: Hello,
and thank you, Minh.
I'll start by sharing
a little about Khan
academy and our
mission, and then I'll
talk about how our use of
the Google Cloud Platform,
including Firestore, helps
us to deliver on the mission.
In particular, today
I'll talk about how
Firestore, along with
App Engine for compute
enabled this to scale rapidly
in the explosion of usage
of our site beginning
with shelter in place
due to the coronavirus pandemic.
For those of you not
familiar with Khan academy,
we're an educational nonprofit.
And our mission is to provide
a free world-class education
for anyone, anywhere.
Many of you will remember
the origins of Khan academy
as founder Sal Khan described
in his early Ted Talks, YouTube
videos that he made
in his walk-in closet,
motivated by his
success in remotely
tutoring his cousin
over the internet.
Today, we are much more
than that collection
of YouTube videos.
Today, Khan academy is the
most effective solution
for accelerating
measurable learning.
We offer free interactive
instructional learning
materials and tools for
core academic subjects
from pre-school through the
first two years of college.
We're a supplemental
resource for teachers
in the classroom
through our personalized
mastery-based
offerings, which focus
on fluency of foundational
skills and concepts.
Efficacy studies show
significant impact
across elementary and middle
school math and in SAT prep.
And I'll pause for
a few seconds to let
you look at these numbers.
In 2019, the Khan
Academy website
served over 94 million
registered users
in 190 countries.
We had over 19 million
monthly active users,
which we define
as users who spend
at least 60 minutes
during the course
of the month on the site.
We served over 240,000
teachers with content
in over 40 languages.
And there were over 15
billion practice questions
completed on the site.
In 2020, beginning in mid-March,
as schools all over the world
abruptly closed because of
the pandemic, and students,
parents, and teachers scrambled
to move to distance learning,
within just two weeks, Khan
Academy site usage grew to 2
1/2 times what it was at
the same time last year.
And we've sustained
that level through June.
We were able to respond
to this rapid growth,
offering our high quality
content and classroom
experience as usual for free.
And in the month of April alone,
we served 30 million learners
on our platform.
A recent national
survey of parents
found that Khan Academy was
the most used online resource.
I'm proud that we
absorbed this rapid growth
without disrupting our users.
In addition to reacting quickly
to alleviate pressure points
within a few days, the
Khan engineering team
had prepared in advance.
And that preparation
paid dividends.
We scaled readily in large part
because of our architecture
and our rigorous
practice of choosing
external services carefully,
and using them properly.
Two fundamental components
of our architecture service
particularly well here,
server-less and caching.
We use GCP, including
App Engine, Datastore,
and Memcached, as well as
other peripheral GCP services.
And these three
were the backbone
of the server-less
and caching strategy
that's key to our scalability.
As you can see in this
diagram, server-less
is a big lever for us.
Using App Engine, a fully
managed environment,
means we can scale very easily
with virtually no effort.
Even with a substantial
traffic increase,
our site stayed up and performed
well with minimal intervention.
We didn't need to worry about
load balancing ourselves
because server instances
were brought up as needed.
Caching also plays a
key role in our scaling.
We use Fastly CDN, which allows
us to cache all static data
and minimize server chips.
Huge for scalability, it
also helps us optimize
hosting resources.
We also extensively cache common
queries, user preferences,
and session data.
And we leverage this to speed
up data fetching performance.
I know you want to hear
about the third work
horse in our mostly
effortless scaling, Firestore.
Firestore scales out storage and
access capacity automatically
in much the same way that
App Engine scales out
web server instances.
We spend very little time
worrying about storage.
Indeed, of the major
parts of our system,
it was the only one we didn't
have to [INAUDIBLE] at all.
App Engine, scaling,
memcache, and task queues
did require a little
tuning, although minimal.
It's really hard
to overemphasize
how easily Firestore scales
without us doing anything
at all.
We have no need to
worry about resharding
or ever about adding capacity.
Here's a look at
our June numbers
to give you a sense of the scale
of our data and site traffic
even in the summer slow month.
Note the 5 to 10x daily
scale-out of sight traffic.
The auto-scaling of both
App Engine and Firestore
helps us to minimize costs since
we pay only for what we used.
I'll end by sharing a couple
of the amazing stories
that our grateful
users have been
sharing with us about
their experiences
as the pandemic started.
Here's one from a teacher.
I'll pause to let you read that.
And here's another
from a doctor working
on the pandemic front lines.
And finally, I want to remind
you that we're a non-profit.
Thanks for having
me today, Minh.
Back to you.
MINH NGUYEN: Thanks, Marta.
It's exciting to see Khan
Academy's broad impact
at an acute time of need.
The Cloud Firestore team is
humbled to help customers
like you make that possible.
Next, I'd like to share
some product announcements.
We wrapped up 2019 with
a class of features
to support richer
queries on Firestore.
This includes
collection groups, along
with IN and
ARRAY-CONTAINS-ANY queries.
We also added support for
increment and decrement
operations.
More recently, we made it easy
for Unity and C++ developers
to adopt Firestore.
It's also now simple to
programmatically create
Firestore databases
using Terraform.
And you can create
those databases
in four new locations bringing
our total global footprint
to 19 locations
around the world.
Moving forward, a major theme
of investment per Firestore
includes metrics and
performance optimization tools.
To support this, we have
launched usage dashboards
and APIs to improve
throughput of both bulk writes
and read operations.
One of the more exciting
features that is coming soon
is a new performance profiler
for Cloud Firestore called
Key Visualizer.
And with that, I
want to hand it over
to Arash, who will be digging a
bit deeper into Key Visualizer.
ARASH PARSA: Thank you, Minh.
Hi.
My name is Arash Parsa, and
I'm a software engineer here
at Cal Firestore.
I'll be talking about
Firestore Key Visualizer, which
is an exciting new feature we
will be launching at the alpha
soon.
Cloud Firestore is built
for automatically scaling
and high performance
out of the box.
There's still, sometimes,
when we talk to our customers,
we hear statements such
as, I'm experiencing
medium latency of
hundreds of milliseconds
for my lookup operations.
Is that expected?
Or, I'm experiencing p99 latency
of order of a few seconds
for my write operations.
Is that normal?
And often, the answer is no.
We commonly find these
performance problems
to be due to the incoming
traffic violating the server's
best practices.
This was an example to
explore one of the ways
an implementation might bite
at these best practices.
I am a new Cloud
Firestore customer,
and I am working on
launching a new API.
In this API, I will simply
receive documents and store
them in my Firestore database.
In this case, I've
implemented a function that
generates the
document IDs for me,
and this function generates
these document IDs
incrementally.
It's worth noting that we
also find these incremental IP
patterns often when
customers are importing
data from other
databases, such as MySQL,
where autoincrementing
ideas are common.
Let's see what kind
of traffic pattern
this implementation
would result to.
As you can see in
this picture, this
will result with sequential
write pattern in my key-space.
Keys are the full paths
to your documents.
So for any given
document, the key
is going to include all the
time collections in addition
to the document idea, which
is the last part of the key.
Firestore is a [INAUDIBLE]
sharded service,
and at any point in
time, your key-space
is going to map to a number
of underlining shards.
The undesired property
of this write pattern
is that at any point in
time, your note is focused
on a single underlying shard.
Cloud Firestore supports
sequential loads
at up to 500
requests per second.
At higher levels of load,
this can result in hotspot.
And for example,
it can show itself
in your API in the form of
elevated latencies or errors.
Cloud Firestore's automatically
scaling capabilities
enables you to scale up
your load to millions
of requests per second.
More specifically,
by following our ramp
up guideline, which suggests
to generally increase
your build by 50%
every five minutes,
you can scale up your
load to tens of millions
of requests per second.
That's still in a
[INAUDIBLE] sharded service
and sequential note
pattern continues to map
to a single shard, and hence,
can result in hotspots.
At Cloud Firestore,
we are constantly
working to provide you
with better features that
can help you diagnose these
type of performance problems.
We are excited to launch Key
Visualizer in alpha soon.
This tool provides
you with visibility
into the traffic
patterns of your database
across the key-space,
and helps you
self-diagnose a number of
different performance problems.
Let's go back to
the customer story
that we were just reviewing.
So in preparation
for my API launch,
I set up load tests
that can hopefully
represent the traffic
that I'm going to receive
during and after my launch.
During these load tests,
I start to observe
that I'm experiencing
some poor performance
for my write operations.
I jumped to the
Key Visualizer view
in order to start to
the debugging process
and get an understanding
of where the root
cause of the problem might be.
Cloud Firestore Key Visualizer
provides two dimensional heat
maps of your project's traffic.
In these heat map views,
the horizontal axis
is time, increasing
from left to right,
and the vertical axis
is your key-space,
with the lower key values
located at the bottom,
and your largest key
is located at the top.
Firestore Key Visualizer heat
map views are two hours wide.
The heating scaled
at the top left
provides the color coding
that is used in this heat map.
In particular, I can see
that black, or dark purple,
indicates that the metric
value is one of the lower
values versus the glowing
whites, which indicates
those regions are carrying
some of the higher
values for this metric.
Firestore Key
Visualizer provides
a number of different metrics,
including your total QPS.
In addition to the
QPS broken down
for your write, look up,
and Query operations,
it also includes latency metrics
for these three RPC categories.
Going back to the example
that we were just reviewing,
I start by examining the
write latencies metric.
Using the provided
color coding here,
I can identify that there
is a sequential load
pattern that is accompanied
with elevated levels of latency.
In particular, I
can find regions
where the average latency can
go as high as a few seconds.
This is certainly not
good and indicates
that there is a
serious performance
degradation happening.
Next, I switched to
the write QPS metric.
Using this metric, I can observe
that this sequential load
pattern is operating at higher
than 5,000 requests per second.
Thinking back about Cloud
Firestore best practices,
I recall that sequential load
patterns are well supported up
to 500 requests per second,
but otherwise at higher levels
of load, they can result
in hotspots and performance
problems.
I can confirm with
my application code
that the document IDs
within this connection
are in fact being
set sequentially.
And this is the likely
source and root cause
of this performance problem.
In this case, I'll go ahead
and change my implementation
to use the Firestore
autogenerated IDs, which
are randomized by default, and
redeploy my code to production.
Next, I can use Key
Visualizer to confirm
that my traffic is
now well distributed
across my key-space, and that
my latencies have moved back
to the normal range.
OK, great.
I was able to use Key
Visualizer to efficiently debug
and resolve a performance issue.
Now, there are a number
of other use cases
that you can actually use Key
Visualizer for performance
debugging.
For instance, in this
case as a customer,
I am able to quickly identify
that collection fuel is
the one that is having
performance issues.
Even though my write
operations look
to be pretty well
distributed in this case,
it seems like there is other
reason that my writes are
performing poorly.
I start by examining
the documents which
are being retained
in this collection
and identify that
these documents are
carrying a field that
contains the time of insertion
of the doc.
Cloud Firestore indexes are
strongly consistent, enhanced
or updated at the time
of your document writes.
This means that if
you're performing
writes with documents that
have sequential field values,
those can also result in
hotspots under indexes.
In the case that you have
documents with sequential field
values, you should either exempt
them from indexing in the case
that you don't need
them for your queries,
or in the case that you
need them for your queries,
you can partition those heavy
write patterns, for instance,
by applying a random prefix to
those sequential field values.
In the case that you
do use this technique,
you would need to re-aggregate
the result on the read side.
OK, so we've reviewed
a couple of examples
where you might
experience performance
problems due to violating
the best practices.
Please continue to review our
full list of best practices
in order to make
sure you're fully
utilizing all of the high
performance capabilities that
are built into Cloud Firestore.
And now, I'm going to hand it
over to Minh to take us home.
MINH NGUYEN: Thank you, Arash.
And thank you to all the
viewers who joined us today.
This concludes our session.
If you haven't signed
up for Cloud Firestore,
we hope you take the opportunity
to get started for free.
If you have questions
about today's presentation,
please feel free to post
your questions on the Dory.
If you'd like to learn more
about how customers are using
Cloud Firestore, we encourage
you to join the New York Times
session, which will
discuss how they
utilize Cloud Firestore in the
power of collaborative editing.
And finally, we
encourage you to join
our large community of
developers on Stack Overflow.
Thank you.